[Music]
george you talk a lot about you you like
talking to the millennials yeah yeah my
wife tells me i was born in the wrong
century often um because you're an old
man
when i joined well that but when i
joined this company
i didn't have social media i had a
ringside seat to years and years and
years of working alongside students and
their parents and high school kids and
college students
and i i just i knew man it's like
hanging out with drug addicts like i'm
not gonna do that i remember when you
started and they were like yeah no
john's not on the internet i'm like how
how does he exist yeah and shockingly i
had a great job and uh
was doing great professionally without
this
without sharing it to the world exactly
how is it possible i was able to eat a
meal all by myself without telling
anybody about it it was a lot of fun
um but this uh wall street journal
article came out the other day
facebook is some released internal
documents facebook knows how toxic
instagram is for teenage girls
um
one of the uh released internal
documents
has things like we know we make body
image issues worse for one in three teen
girls
um instagram increases the rate of
anxiety and depression these are from
internally released facebook documents
and if you don't know facebook owns
instagram
um among teens who reported suicidal
thoughts 13 of british users six percent
of american users trace the desire to
take their own life
to social media
and here's the thing
i've got a fifth grade i've got a sixth
grader now but last year in fifth grade
um just at a local public school my son
came home one day head held low
dad i'm the only kid in fifth grade
that doesn't have tick tock that doesn't
have social media and i sat him down
said son i've been telling you for years
that your parents are weird
and that this day would come and i'm
sorry um i i know that that makes you
the odd kid in class it turns out he
wasn't turns out parents we've connected
over that actually like oh man you want
your kids to connect with other real
human beings and
have uh real relationships
but the data is emerging
and
especially among my mental health
colleagues across the country
social media is destroying our children
and i can't say it any more emphatically
it's destroying our children i know that
we think we are helping them by giving
them these digital babysitters and
saying you connect with your friends and
this is helpful it is not george and
it's creating this all universe these
false realities it's hacking our our
internal
um neural chemicals and our our
fight-or-flight responses it's just
destroying children and it's not helping
adults either here's the sucky part
george i never had it until i got it for
this job
and then i find myself like my kids are
saying dad you want to come play i'm
like oh look kids and i'm scrolling
through this thing and i thought oh no
yeah i'm an addict too now right it's a
vortex
so what are some examples what are some
some
um i don't know some things you would
recommend to millennials to all now i
mean i'm you know
facebook's taking over for adults too 67
it's one of my my grandfather who's
still alive he's in his 90s when he
friended me on facebook in college i
remember thinking i'm done here like i
remember this probably
um what do you what do you
what do you recommend to folks to get
off this stuff and to reconnect with
human beings one of the biggest things
i've found is that to remind yourself
that you
have control of who you follow no no you
don't george you can control that john
unfollow button they send me you know
what the algorithm we've put you through
our computers whoever they is we think
you'll like these people and they're
usually right well you've been
advertised for you know supplements and
things that hey john you could be
stronger and more tan and all these
different things and one of the keys
that i felt that i could ever get more
tangible is you got to get away from the
comparisons that's where a lot of this
anxiety stress mental health illness is
coming from because you're going i'm not
there yet how come all my friends how
come all these people are living lives
so much better than mine my life sucks
yeah you've got to take a step back
maybe delete the app for a little bit
and get back to reality and so when you
just said delete the app millions of
people's eyes rolled in the back of
their heads i'm not doing it john not
doing it not doing it here's my
challenge
take social media off your phones for a
week take them away from your kids try
for a day i bet they couldn't do that
that's right for a day and i want you
and your kids this can be crazy i want
you all to talk to one another i want
you to interact with each other i want
you to look at your spouse and say hi uh
how are you
try that see what happens